welcome to CBS this morning we're going
to begin with your big explosive
interview with our Kelly Wow he had a
lot to get off his chest nor he actually
said he welcomed the opportunity to
speak and boy did we let him speak and
everybody has switched their channels on
to us to see it this morning him speak
so let's get right to it because our
Kelly is breaking his silence about the
sexual abuse charges that landed him in
jail last month the embattled R&B singer
spoke with Gail for nearly 80 minutes
yesterday it is an interview that you
will see only on CBS this morning and he
says all the women now accusing him of
physical and sexual abuse he says all of
them are lying that's what he says
Chicago prosecutors have charged Kelly
with 10 counts of aggravated criminal
sexual abuse authorities say three of
the four alleged victims were underage
when the suspected crimes happened
Kelly has pleaded not guilty sources
tell CBS News federal and state
authorities in at least two states New
York and Illinois are now investigating
a variety of allegations the singer as
you know has faced intense scrutiny for
more than a decade now
it was reignited in January after the
lifetime docucentre views with seven
accusers and former members of his inner
circle they all say that Kelly preys on
vulnerable women and young girls I am
surprised that you agreed to do it why
are you sitting down with us today I'm
very tired of all of the lies I've been
hearing things and you know and seeing
things on the blog's and you know I'm
just I'm just tired what are the lies
that you're hearing that disturb your
mouth oh my god all of them that little
girl is trapped in the basement
helicopters over my house trying to
rescue someone that doesn't need
rescuing because they're not in my house
handcuffing people starving people I
have a harem what you call it here my
coat really know what a coldie is but I
know I don't have one
you know have you done anything that you
regret have you done anything wrong
lots of things wrong when it comes to
women that I apologize but I apologize
in those relationships at the time I was
in the relationships broken any laws
when it comes to women absolutely not
the six-part series interviewed 50
people mm-hmm family members your former
tour manager numerous women who all
claim that you abused them
are you saying everybody in that
documentary was not telling the truth
about you everybody if you really look
at that documentary which I'm sure you
have I have everybody say something bad
about me nobody said nothing could they
was describing Lucifer my Lucifer I'm a
man I make mistakes but I'm not a devil
and by no means am i a monster I'm gonna
name the names Andrea Kelly your ex-wife
Kitty Jones Lisa Van Alen
Lisette Martinez jaronda pace faith
Rogers Asante McGee you're saying
everything they said in that documentary
about you is not true they are lying on
me why would these women say the same
thing about you that you are controlling
that you were abusive that you tell
women when to eat when to go to the
bathroom when they can sleep where they
can dress why would all these women tell
these different stories about you if
they were not true and they don't know
each other that defies logic to me
right right until you hear the
explanation you can start a rumor on a
guy like me or a celebrity just like
that all you have to do is push a button
on your phone and say so-and-so did this
to me are Kelly did this to me and if
you get any traction from that if you if
you're able to write a book from that if
you're able to get a reality show then
any girl that I had a relationship in
the past that I it just didn't work out
she can come and say the same exact
thing
are you blaming this on social media I'm
talking about the power of social media
in 2008 our Kelly was found not guilty
on 14 counts of child pornography after
prosecutors in Chicago failed to
convince
hurry that he was a man seen in a sex
tape with a girl as young as 13 last
month Kelly was indicted again this time
charged with aggravated criminal sexual
abuse of four women including three who
the charges say were minors at the time
have you ever had sex of anyone under
the age of seven no never no I have to
tell you it's so hard to believe that
based on all of this about you women
said about me what women so nobody's
allowed to be mad at me and be scorned
and allowed me so they're lying on you
that's your explanation they're lying on
you absolutely absolutely you feel that
people have maligned your could have
been assassinated I have been buried
alive one of my life so I think the
point you're making is and and correct
me if I'm wrong that you have never held
anybody against their will I don't need
to say why would I
well I'm out stupid with never helping
our Kelly with all I've been through in
my way way past to hold somebody let
alone four five six fifty you say it how
stupid would I be to do that I didn't
say yes stupid guys I didn't is this
camera on me yes that's stupid
use your common sense don't forget the
blocks forget how you feel about me hate
me if you want to love me if you want
but just use your common sense how
stupid would it be for me to with my
crazy passing what I've been through oh
right now I just think I need to be a
monster and hold girls against they will
chain them up in my basement and and
don't let them eat and don't let them
out unless they need some shoes down the
street from the uncle hop it got quit
playing quit playing I didn't do this
stuff this is not me I'm fighting for my
life no
[Music]
relationship with my kids and I can't do
it don't just don't want to believe it -
you don't want to believe it at this
point we briefly pause the interview to
give Kelly a moment this publicist
helped calm him down I hope this time
will keep going no we're gonna visit
ruling this isn't that doesn't even make
sense why would I hold all these women
their mothers at father's told me we're
going to destroy your career but Kelly's
emotions remained raw it's real girls
out there missing it's real young girls
out there being abducted being raped
okay they really are on chains they
really do have chains on their on their
wrists and they can't get out ended up
buried in Robert we have to have a
conversation I don't want you just
ranting at the camera
I came here for them to hear help what
kind of help this is the kind of help I
need yes what kind of help I need
somebody to help me not have a big heart
because my heart is so big people
betrayed me keep giving them you sound
like you're playing the victim here
you sound like our Kelly you do listen
to me you're playing the victim I'm just
telling the truth
and the reason I'm a mold it Robert
apologized for that no because this is
the first time I was able to say
something I've said nothing Gail you
remained tough and calm throughout that
well I mean it wouldn't do any good if
we both got hysterical or if we got if
we both got very emotional and you could
see he felt that in his mind everybody's
lying I said but there's so many people
who are telling the same story he kept
going back going back I said but in the
women don't know each other and he said
how do you know they don't know each
other on social media you're connected
he thinks everybody's trying to do a
book deal or they're trying to do a
movie and that really are people are
conspiring against him I have to
I've never seen anything like that what
was he like before the interview because
you didn't really know him that well no
I don't he got very emotional several
times I met him maybe beyond five years
ago at a party where you just say hi how
are you you know it's not the time you
say remember we met five years ago I
hate it when people do that so I did a
scan we have a have a conversation
before the interview got started I
wanted to say we're gonna give you a
platform to say whatever you want to say
it's no secret that he lives at Trump
Tower and in Chicago so we went to his
apartment there and we had a
conversation and you walk into his
apartment there's a big welcome home
there's a Christmas tree that he keeps
up all year long since his mother died
back in 1993 he's very close to his
mother misses her very much because it
was her favorite holiday so he keeps a
Christmas tree up all year long it was
like 90 degrees in there because he was
resting his voice he said he was going
to be singing later but what he has
accused of his dastardly exactly what
you did Gail was allow him to tell his
story and to see though his behavior his
temperament is I think what is probably
what is most revealing of this interview
as well the pounding of the fists that
getting up I was worried about you I was
actually worried about you when I saw
the pictures well it's funny a favorite
son favorite daughter and Oprah all
called me and said were you afraid did
you think he was going to hit you I
actually never thought that I think that
he was I thought I might get
accidentally clobbered but I didn't
think that he would deliberately try to
hurt me I never felt in danger talking
to him I just felt that he had a lot of
emotion he wanted to release it and you
know when it was all over we had a
conversation we said goodbye and I think
at the end of the day he was glad that
he was able to say what he wanted to say
okay even if but it's hard to believe
when you say Robert there are so many
allegations and so many accusations and
you've never had sex with anybody under
the age of 17 and it took this jury less
than a day to deliberate yes exactly
exactly right there's more sitting right
and he says more will come out on his
side of the story too